satellite images showed the aftermath of
combat amid ongoing fighting between
russian and ukrainian forces
smoke billowed from a damaged aircraft
hangar outside kiev as russian forces
targeted key infrastructure including a
major fuel depot russian forces didn't
capture major cities over the weekend
the news agency story full set it
corroborated and verified the location
of this footage which shows ukrainian
forces examining abandoned russian
military vehicles
and an exchange of gunfire breaking out
in ukraine's second largest city
the fighting continues across several
cities but the ukrainian military so far
managed to put up a really fierce
resistance
it's notable that many ordinary citizens
have taken up arms to defend their
nation and also resorted to making crude
homemade weapons for protection such as
molotov cocktails
however many ukrainians who chose not to
remain headed to train stations to
depart for neighboring countries while
others prepared to drive across the
border
in a first for the european union the
bloc said member countries will supply
ukraine with jet fighters this is a
watershed moment
the u.s and european governments also
announced new sanctions that would cut
off several russian banks from the
global financial messaging system swift
as the west stepped up pressure against
moscow president vladimir putin ordered
the country's nuclear forces to be put
on high alert
on monday a delegation led by ukraine's
defense minister arrived for talks with
russian officials at the ukrainian
border with belarus the first talks
since moscow's invasion
the fact that neither president was
present doesn't bode well because it's
really these two men who need to start
talking in order for there to be some
kind of preparations towards any kind of
compromise